on a scale of one to ten ten being
amazing how do you rate this pink blazer
i love it i feel like you could have
been on stage with us last night
i'm i was gonna wear something else
you're loving las vegas ready let me
tell you i saw you with that pink suit
on stage last night i was like okay he's
gonna appreciate this
first of all congratulations on opening
night i know you're a great singer
you're such a good showman it was such a
good show thank you how's it feel having
your own show here in vegas it's amazing
you know i i uh wanted this show to to
be
not just a
a a concert i wanted to be a full
experience where you get to understand a
bit more of my journey but also where we
embrace the full vegas energy we we
brought the big production we brought
the
showgirl dancers we brought everything
and uh we felt like we wanted to do it
big for vegas and i think we did it you
definitely succeeded and then hearing
everybody like knowing all the words to
your songs everyone getting up and
dancing it was really fun to see chrissy
in the audience we got to see miles
sleeping yes
is this common for him well he
goes to bed when he's ready
it doesn't matter how loud
he can sleep anywhere i'm actually the
same way yeah uh so he's like me and uh
he usually goes to bed around 7 45 8
o'clock
and uh the show started around 8 20 so
it was already well past his bedtime um
are they still impressed when you sing
or are they at the point where they're
like yeah dad we get it you're an
amazing singer
they really do enjoy my music and they
get to hear my new music before everyone
else i get to play it in the car for
them and they're like uh i can tell
which ones they like more than others so
they're like my first like audience test
too oh are they brutally honest not real
well they really love the music honestly
they're like my biggest fans too so uh
miles i think i'm his favorite artist
yeah i'm like probably three or four
behind rihanna ariana grande
listen those are selena gomez she likes
the ladies of pop yeah those are tough
acts to me um okay so love in las vegas
love the name for this show you know at
this stage in your life how do you
define love
well
that's an interesting question but you
know i i felt so much love in the room
last night yeah
part of what i love about making music
is that it connects people and and it's
a way of transmitting love and positive
energy out to people every night and so
i get to do this on stage and it's such
a beautiful feeling and i love what i do
that's we can tell because we can see
the passion
you